they sing the rider burns you he burns
your soul
agents of shield ghostrider Tuesday
September 20th new time 10:00 9:00
central ABC hey youtubers it's Charlie
so we got Robby Rhea's footage of the
actual car in Ghost Rider form looks
like it's just gonna make everybody go
splat so let's break it down so the
whole idea here is they're just showing
you what the car is going to look like
most of the time I can't even imagine
how expensive it would be to have the
whole thing engulfed in flames
constantly while it was on screen all
the time so from a practical perspective
I think what they've done is they found
like a fun way to film the car like
something that's really cool on screen
without just completely depleting their
budget that'd be a dope way to end any
TV show like you have one CG character
that's just so expensive to do that you
can only do the show for like a couple
episodes so you're like okay what we're
going to do is we're going to have that
CG character just go around and kill all
of the other characters so that the
show's over but the thing here I think
that doing this the right way too is
they're not having the Ghost Rider
character speak like you just see him
you hear other characters talking about
him they say when the writer burns you
he burned your soul the car itself has
some different abilities when he is in
Ghost Rider form like when he is fully
flame on Ghost Rider he can actually
walk right through it as if it's nothing
he can pilot it remotely and if he's not
standing right next to the car he can
actually teleport inside of it so like
he doesn't have to open the door to get
inside he can just willed himself inside
the car but that's only when he's in
Ghost Rider form not when he's just
walking around as normal Robby Reyes so
I don't know how they're gonna deal with
that on the show there's actually a
couple easy ways for them to film stuff
like that but like the car itself as a
normal car so like it just drives around
like a normal car would when he's not
Ghost Rider but if you read any of the
Ghost Rider comics or you seen any of
the Ghost Rider movies you know that
when Johnny Blaze is riding his
motorcycle when he's Ghost Rider it
gains all these extra abilities that
normal motorcycles don't have so just
expect them to have some fun with some
really crazy WTF action set-pieces with
the car which i think is a nice addition
there haven't been a lot of vehicle
stunts since like the first couple
seasons agents of show like they've done
some motorcycle work they had a little
fun with the cloaking device on quinjets
but I think the
Carr is going to be a little bit more
fun to actually watch week to week I've
already talked a little bit about Robbie
ray is back story in the comics but he
basically merges with this other spirit
it's not quite the same thing as Johnny
Blaze it's not like a biblical spirit of
vengeance so we don't know if he has all
the same abilities as the Johnny Blaze
Ghost Rider like the penance stare or if
he can manifest chains and things from
his mouth or if he can discharge
Hellfire from guns like when Johnny
Blaze uses a gun it can discharge
magical fire he's still going to be
really powerful no matter what but I
think we'll get a good idea for how
powerful in the first couple of episodes
like there will be some limits but just
for example in the comics Doctor Strange
says that Johnny Blaze when he's in
Ghost Rider form is more powerful than
the version of Hulk during Planet Hulk
and World War Hulk like the gladiator
Hulk persona which is way crazier than
normal Hulk so basically Ghost Rider for
all intents and purposes on agents of
shield is kind of like a game changer
character but because of who he is
because of the Ghost Rider persona he's
kind of a wild card so you can imagine
how shields gonna react to that it's
gonna be a lot of fun watching them try
to get him on the team but even though
they're continuing to do inhuman stuff
they did tease that they would be doing
you know royal family like deep cuts
from the Inhumans comics I don't think
they're going to tie Ghost Rider to any
of that stuff I think they'll be
relatively true to the comics because it
said part of the idea in doing Ghost
Rider this season is because they're
doing more mystical doctor strange
things in the movies they're moving to
new territory in the MCU they want it to
follow suit on the TV show so the like
okay Ghost Rider is just like a really
fun visual way to push into the magical
realm that we can totally do on TV
because there is no way that they're
going to make another Ghost Rider movie
anytime soon but for those you asking
there is a chance that Ghost Rider could
totally appear in the movies eventually
but I would expect it to be relatively
small and if he does go somewhere else
in the MCU I really think it's going to
be on the Netflix shows that would be a
lot of fun just have them show up in
like the Punisher series maybe an Iron
Fist series at a certain point maybe
like the second season of iron fist
because they're pretty much done filming
that show in fact one of the cast
members from iron fist who plays Colleen
wing is a sand snake on Game of Thrones
she just went back to Belfast
so I think they're pretty much done
filming most of Iron Fist series but
they'll probably be more news about that
later this year after Luke Cage drops
which is actually in a couple weeks
agents of shield coming back on the 20th
Luke Cage is coming back the week after
that so it's like back-to-back Marvel TV
shows dropping it's gonna be a lot of
fun so be sure to subscribe to get all
those videos I'll be doing videos for
agents of shield and for Luke Cage it'll
be a little bit different from Luke Cage
because it's all dropping at once so the
Luke Cage stuff will post a little bit
more like when I was doing daredevil
season 2 earlier this year where it's
like one video every couple days and
people that have seen it so far say it
is like the best Marvel Netflix series
so far so I cannot wait to see all this
stuff so next video will be spider-man
homecoming they've been posting more
behind the scenes stuff there's some
interesting differences in the way
they're doing mocap for spider-man
homecoming it gets evolved a little bit
since they've done Civil War so a whole
bunch of really cool behind the scenes
spider-man stuff coming soon what you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for Avengers infinity war behind
the scenes you can click here for the
last big Luke Cage trailer again thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five sweet Christmas stuff coming
back real soon